[Musique]
paris et sa petite couronne vont devoir
se plier à de nouvelles restrictions
protocole sanitaire renforcée pour les
restaurateurs qui échappe à la fermeture
totale de leur établissement à la
différence des bars contraints de fermer
leurs portes en région parisienne à
paris en tout cas nous pourrons
continuer à aller si j'ai bien compris
au restaurant sous certaines sections
mais pas dans les bars non ça ne me
gênera pas trop je les fréquente pas
assidûment rothenbach tôt ce métal
isolement pour une semaine la mise de la
culture est considéré comme un cas
contacts que vidal a partagé un repas
vendredi soir avec une personne
diagnostiquée dimanche positif au co
vide
je sais que pour les franciliens c'est
une nouvelle très dur à entendre
parce que parce qu'on n'avait pensé que
le virus était derrière nous et que
aujourd'hui il va falloir faire preuve à
nouveau d'autodiscipline flée restaurant
de marseille et d'aix
ils vont pouvoir rouvrir sous contrainte
c'est une bonne nouvelle le gouvernement
a mis de l'eau dans son vin si je puis
dire oui c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que très sincèrement on a été confronté
à des décisions qui ont été mal compris
ce gouvernement a compris qu'il avait
fait je dirais presque n'importe quoi
sur marseille et qu' il revient sur ce
qu'ils aiment paris des familles de
faire d'ailleurs nous adaptons sans
cesse à la réalité de l'épidémie à la
réalité du virus et qu'il faut en
permanence trouver cet équilibre entre
la préservation de la santé de nos
concitoyens et la réalité et les
nécessités de la continuité de la vie
économique et sociale
nous serons extrêmement vigilants
effectivement à ce qu'il y ait toute
cette transparence et que dans quinze
jours même s'il y en a des rendez vous
entre nous quotidien dans 15 jours nous
puissions sortir de cette situation
jeudi à la droite ne restez pas sur le
banc de touche pendant 20 ans alors que
nous possédons des valeurs de grande
qualité et que je préfère les
médications participe au gouvernement je
rappelle que jean castex et
l'ip et doit edouard philippe sandra de
l'année c'est ce sont quand même dans ce
vivier lac emmanuel macron est allé
chercher ses deux premiers ministres et
qu'il leur a fait confiance je vais
grandir mon joker a dit simon statut
acteurs ne me permet pas de dire mes
préférences pour la prochaine élection
si vite c'est une valeur sûre pour la
france et d'un rhume soit je les lis je
le crois donald trump qui salue ses
partisans depuis sa voiture à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital
iny revenu depuis d'après son équipe
médicale il pourrait revenir aujourd'hui
à la maison blanche
[Musique]
et
elle trompe pas d'abord pris un
traitement expérimental des anticorps de
synthèse donc fabriqué en laboratoire
par la firme régénérant dont le pdg est
un partenaire de golf de trump ce
traitement qui n'a pas encore été
autorisé sur le marché n'en est qu'à la
phase de test il a pourtant été
administré à la dose maximale de 8 g
c'est un traitement de cheval ou un
petit peu oui c'est un traitement de
cheval
pourquoi parquet seulement qu'est ce que
ça peut vouloir dire probablement pour
le mettre sur pied le plus vite possible
[Musique]